moskau die hauptstadt russlands eine
millionen metropole mit zwei gesichtern
weltoffen und modern aber zugleich
streng und traditionell
wir begleiten sechs schweizern
schweizerinnen die den mut hatten sich
im wilden osten niederzulassen
in dieser fremden geheimnisvollen welt
die unter präsident putin wieder an die
goldenen zeiten anknüpfen möchte weshalb
haben sich unsere schweizer diesen ort
ausgesucht wie heimisch fühlen sie sich
hier und mit welchen schwierigkeiten
sind sie täglich konfrontiert
traum oder albtraum abenteuer moskau
[Musik]
es ist samstagmorgen lawrence witmer und
seine familie tun das was die meisten
anderen einwohner der
zwölf-millionen-metropole auch tun
sie fahren übers wochenende raus auf die
datscha lorenz caroline und die kinder
besuchen schweizer freunde schon die
reise dorthin in einem derartigen
regionalzüge ist ein kleines abenteuer
die datscha der freunde liegt in kaluga
rund 180 kilometer südlich von moskau
die letzte etappe führt durch den wald
zum glück kennt lorenz den weg oder etwa
doch nicht
[Musik]
natürlich irgendwie hatte ich irgendwie
würde es den schweif hinter glaubst du
dir coldest unterwegs sind jekaterinburg
die metropole jenseits des urals ist ein
austragungsort der fußball-wm die
bauarbeiten ziehen viele in- und
ausländische gastarbeiter an bord er
besucht eine lokale ngo welche von der
schweiz unterstützt wird und sich um den
schutz der arbeiter kümmert eine neue
broschüre soll die arbeitsmigranten über
ihre rechte aufklären
das sind juristische ratschläge die an
die arbeiter verteilt werden zb ein
arbeitsvertrag sowie eher aufgesetzt
sein sollte oftmals wissen die arbeiter
das nicht hier haben sie ein beispiel
zielgruppen sind die arbeiter die hier
auf den baustellen tätig sind
sie sollen korrekt und nicht ausgebeutet
werden löhne erhalten
sie müssen ihre rechte und pflichten
kennen die geschichte insbesondere bei
den olympischen winterspielen in sotschi
hat gezeigt migranten sind gefährdet
es gibt immer die gefahr dass sie
ausgebeutet werden die baufirmen sind
sehr unterschiedlich natürlich gibt es
risiken
das sind not schlafstätten wo obdachlose
vorübergehend unterkunft finden
wir hatten hier schon leute die waren
als sklaven gehalten worden
letztes jahr kam einer der war zuvor
zehn jahre sklave in kasachstan
er meinte man habe ihn für drei schafe
verkauft erkennen jetzt seinen preis die
polizei zu der geflüchtet sei habe ihn
für so viel verkauft der neueste stolz
der ngo als kido eine medizinische
notfallstation für migranten
diese werde auch von einheimischen
genutzt und sei selbst tragend ein
bürokratischer krampf sei es gewesen
aber es habe schließlich doch ohne
schmiergeld geklappt zurück in moskau
mitnimmt zentrum baut die schweiz ihr
neues botschaftsgebäude
und er trägt die verantwortung dass
alles gut kommt roland lay
die zeit drängt wie immer doch der
61-jährige ist optimistisch die arbeiten
gehen dem ende zu auch wenn es für den
laien noch nicht so aussieht
es kommt also fast fertig gezeichnet
oder für russisches fertig relativ
schnell zu erreichen wo mehr hat einfach
mit diesem schweizerische
qualitätsdenken noch nicht zufrieden
sind
das neue gebäude beinhaltet im
eingangsbereich einen alten historischen
kern diesen originalgetreu zu
restaurieren war eine bautechnische
herausforderung das thema e10 gang zur
residenz also wo die empfängt
stattfindet das muss natürlich
repräsentativ sie alle verkleidung all
die stuckaturen da camera jetzt wieder
so gemacht ist ruhig sie sind das mache
mit russische liter können sehr gut da
sind zentral mit gips schaftler formel
gewerbe schlief
wallace spachtel dass man nicht sehr
genau funktioniert gut
eine verwunschene dacia vor den toren
moskaus
es ist das elternhaus von svetlana
guggenbühl
die café händlerin hat hier die ersten
acht jahre ihrer kindheit verbracht als
ihr vater anfing geschäfte in moskau zu
machen
heute wohnt hier nur noch eine tante
doch svetlana flüchtet oft hierher vor
allem in hektischen zeiten wenn sie
etwas ruhe braucht es für mich besinnen
und ich bin natürlich außer russische
sprache selber backt am hus müssen immer
wieder notwendige mit sei nichts weiter
als erster skoda
ich weiß nicht was er genau damit ist
alles fake know how von der schweiz und
und dem rektor der hand angelegt und
oder wenn er mal auf dem teller gebracht
in smetanas alten kinderzimmer ist die
zeit stehengeblieben
ich konnte mir gerne live
schlafzimmermöbel stellen immer nur
genau gleichen früheren städtischen
eigentlich ort und lampe die aktie aber
spielsachen sind halt so langsam langsam
täglich fährt die 26 jährige hat in
zürich und london gelebt aber das
einfache russische leben ihrer kindheit
schätzt sie bis heute sehr dass im
garten immer alle turnierspiele sie
leben mit normalen spielsachen gespielt
mitbürger aber ich weiß noch wo
militante selbst ein was ich kann ist
ein gameboy und auf den sinn einfach zum
gameboy xii
[Musik]
moskau zeigt sich von seiner schönsten
seite
hotelmanager dominik oder und chefkoch
andré schmack of nutzen denn sommertag
für eine einkaufstour
sie fahren mit der metro in richtung
osten der stadt
ihr ziel ein bekannter obst und
gemüsemarkt namens priora schelsky das
ist eigentlich ein markt wo deren
quartier handlichen markt mexiko
hier haben frauen viel gutes produkt
musik produziert findet eines der ziele
ist die richtigen äpfel für den
wellnessbereich zu finden
gute produkte waren lange rar
russland hatte als reaktion auf die
sanktionen landwirtschafts importe aus
dem westen verboten
das führte zu engpässen war aber auch
der startschuss zur selbsthilfe sehr
schwierig sie überhaupt nur die produkt
gründer bis ich das alles passte die
vielfalt der flucht und mir das herz
entsprechen das embargo ein positives
klick jetzt hier für lokale marken
tomaten sind zb jetzt richtig gut
ich habe mit computer der kasseler das
ist die region am schwarzen meer ich und
die hand ganz tief rote verhalten und
wirken richtig starke authentische
tomate gemacht was man hier auch an
trifft sind landwirtschaftsprodukte aus
der von russland annektierten
ukrainischen halbinsel krim produkte von
der krim zu kaufen bringt das skoda in
eine politische zwickmühle
mit einer lügt nicht richtige regelmäßig
mit einer frage des typs genau warum
aber ich glaube nicht dass ihr produkt
das die christen und politischer sind
die eier schwämme und das andere pilze
die stammen direkt aus dem moskauer
vorort auch für willi berchtold steht
heute ein außentermin an die bernerin
berät schweizer firmen die in russland
unternehmerisch tätig werden wollen
gemeinsam mit ihrem kollegen anatoli
trifft sie heute alexander konvois er
ist direktor der schweizer united
machinery ag einer firma die sich auf
nischenprodukte für eisenbahntechnik
spezialisiert hat nicht zuletzt dank
schülers unterstützung vertreibt er
diese produkte nun auch erfolgreich auf
dem russischen markt
die nachfrage ist trotz der krise stabil
und die konkurrenz aus china kann in
diesem markt nur bedingt mithalten
die qualität asiatischer produkte nimmt
zu allerdings sind eben auch die preise
gestiegen
die schweiz ist nach wie vor die adresse
für einzigartige hightech lösungen
zudem findet man diese speziellen
produkte in china eben manchmal nicht
wir haben eigentlich vom ersten tag an
mit der schweizer botschaft und dem
schweizer business hub kooperiert und
ich würde sagen es ist ein vorteil für
beide seiten
von der globalen weltwirtschaft hin zur
beschaulichen landwirtschaft schweizer
idealisten lorenz und seine familie
haben inzwischen die datscha der
schweizer freunde gefunden
werner und seine frau andrea betreiben
ein kleines reiseunternehmen und haben
sich hier einen dacia paradies
erschaffen
[Musik]
lorenz und carolin haben sich an den
kosten beteiligt und dafür ein
nutzungsrecht erworben
eigenhändig importiert lager für das
schon gesagt habe vier kinder vor allem
dadurch die superlative in der deutsche
tv mitmachen mitmachen heißt auch mit
anpacken
schließlich sollen die erdbeeren heute
noch in die erde
lorenz schätzt aber auf rang mit
händischen ich finde es wichtig dass
cancellaras ziemlich kommt und dass sie
auch noch enteilen
freiheit pur apropos freiheit wie ist es
für die freunde in russland spürt berno
als westeuropäer die mächtige hand von
präsident putin und vanille und lietz
moskau vor allem mit einem mit politics
zuhört dann müssen für die chance
was derzeit über die wir uns persönlich
hervorgetan aber fix mit frank falsche
super baustellenbesichtigung in
jekaterinburg helm auf auch für dorothea
hier entsteht ein hotel gegenüber dem
neu renovierten fußballstadion viele
arbeiter sind serben aber es hat auch
zentralasiaten hier sei alles in ordnung
versichert das zentralstadion des fc
ural wird für die wm mit temporären
rekonstruktionen auf 35.000 sitzplätze
erweitert
ein besuch dort sei schwierig heißt es
hier habe ich einen guten eindruck
ich habe mit den leuten geredet es
scheint gut zu sein aber ich bin
natürlich keine helferin und weiß nicht
ob es versteckte probleme gibt sicher
wollen sie uns ein gutes beispiel zeigen
unsere partner der ngo werden uns aber
schon erzählen wenn es beschwerden geben
sollte das würde mich natürlich
interessieren aber das werde ich hier
sicher nicht direkt fragen
zeit zum diskutieren gibt es im
nahegelegenen kaufhaus für die endlos
ist es ein risiko mit westlichen
partnern zusammenzuarbeiten
der kreml sich das nicht gerne wenn
russische organisationen geld aus dem
westen erhalten und bezeichnet sie dann
häufig öffentlich als ausländische
agenten dorotheas nächste station ein
menschenrecht seminar es liegt einiges
im argen zwischen russland und dem
westen hat sie das gefühl wir sind immer
ein bisschen weniger willkommen
sie argumentieren immer häufiger sie als
russen hätten ihre traditionellen werte
wir sollten besser schauen was bei uns
läuft bevor wir zu ihnen kommen von
menschenrechten zu sprechen oder von
demokratie ist unpopulär geworden
irgendwie besteht einfach ein riesiges
missverständnis zwischen russland und
dem westen
zurück in moskau auf der baustelle der
schweizer botschaft gibt es einen
kleinen einblick in das neue zuhause des
ranghöchsten diplomaten hier in russland
das ist zukünftige wohnzimmer von
botschafter also die ganz logisch für
die botschafter da hinein trat im
bürobereich und heraus ist büro fassaden
ist holz glas fassade kommt aus der
schweiz
die hohe qualität mit einer tochter wie
auch die ganze möbel baute das kommt
alles lustig wie für russische
verhältnisse nur die ex aequo die
oligarchen ist das ein mittleres
standort habe ich denke für als
schweizer botschaft dass präsentiere
denke wenn man alles wusste schon dass
es gut ist gesetze noch viel besser aus
dass bauunternehmer roland sich manchmal
über die lokalen eigenarten seiner
arbeiter ärgern muss gehört dazu
heute hat offenbar einer zu früh
feierabend gemacht
das ist die bestell exekutiv kommunale
liegt 14 heads am boden
grüße in die b 14 as rom
zu allem überfluss steckt rolands house
band angeblichen schwierigkeiten wie
ernst ist es schwierig zum sieg in die
hof von etwas da ganz schlimm ich will
meinte dass sie machten insgesamt sind
einige musik banken sind klasse wurde
der krise diesmal das problem ist
wenn man mit der us banken und die
wirtschaft und die schwierigkeiten weiß
man nicht wie es denn in zukunft geht um
mehr hinter bankgarantie und das thema
lokale folgen
dunkle wolken wo man nur hinschaut der
sommer in moskau ist dieses jahr ein
reinfall wurde asphalt sonst glüht gibt
es nur schützen
alles in allem ein tag an dem man das
haus nur verlässt wenn man unbedingt
muss die nacht aber dass er wird als
jetzt
[Musik]
juli trifft einen alten freund der ihr
während ihrer anfangszeit in moskau
2002 viel beigebracht hat nicolai login
er arbeitet in der russischen redaktion
von radio sputnik den russischen ausland
funk der sender hieß früher die stimme
russlands und berichtete damals auch
kritischer nicolai ein kluger geist weiß
natürlich wie sein präsident im westen
wahrgenommen werden will
die stärke ruf lanz wird manchmal in
europa als zeichen der aggressivität
aggressivität betrachtet aber man muss
ja natürlich stark sein wenn du frei und
selbstständig sein will
deswegen hat guten jetzt große
popularität im volk
natürlich spielt hier das fernsehen eine
rolle wenn man niemals sagt also putin
hat das gemacht dass gemacht dass ge
macht keine fehler gemacht dann ist es
ja in folge
entsteht der eindruck putin ist unser
alles juli hat selbst bei der stimme
russlands gearbeitet
nicolai war damals ihr mentor und gab
ihr ein paar wichtige verhaltensregeln
mit von denen sie bis heute profitiert
wird aber ist das land hat eine
besondere nacht im hotel metropol der
erste moskauer restaurant führer von
bormio wird präsentiert in russland gab
es so etwas bis jetzt noch nicht
erwartet wird die gastro elite von ganz
moskau
chefkoch andré schmackhaft und seine
leute bereiten den anlass seit drei
tagen vor
hier haben wir mit deutsch leber und
hier pastete heute gibt es lammkeule
daneben noch angriff fleischgerichte die
schmutter rippen und truthahn zum
trinken gibt es selbst gemacht rendova
geriebener meerrettich honig
lorbeerblätter sellerie familie stressen
lasse er sich nicht obwohl die härteste
konkurrenz der stadt zu gast ist wenn du
nervös bis aller stress hast überträgt
sich das auch das essen das du kochst es
kann schlecht werden ruhig und locker
bleiben dann wird alles toll und fein
wer von den starköchen heute abend von
den französischen gummi spezialisten
eine auszeichnung erhält kann sich etwas
darauf einbilden domenico da hofft
natürlich dass das hauseigene restaurant
in die ränge kommt
[Musik]
es geht aber sicher toll wenn die
mediziner sagen wir ihn mal unter der
nächsten zeit das war schon toll wenn es
drinnen ist uns gut bewertet ist dann
wird es natürlich auch einfluss ihres
vereins darstelle wiederum vor allem auf
moskowiter also die kundschaft war hier
vor ort ist aber natürlich auch
ausländische kundschaft will ja wenn man
es macht und man kulinarisch
interessierten wie auguste was gibt es
denn restaurant
drei finalisten werden in jeder
kategorie vorgestellt dann der sieger
gekürt
bei der wahl zum besten hotel koch ist
auch an der schmack vom metropol
nominiert er gewinnt und auch das
hoteleigene restaurant sava erreicht in
der kategorie restaurant einen guten
dritten platz
die ihn oft sind die holen
ein etappensieg
mehr nicht so lange wird er mit seiner
familie in einer fernbeziehung leben
ein neuer tag rund 1500 kilometer
östlich von moskau in jekaterinburg im
museum zu ehren von boris jelzin dem
ersten präsidenten des neuen russlands
ein museum das bei dorothea viele
erinnerungen wachruft das hier ist sowie
daran erinnere ich mich bereits 1989
verbrachte sie ein jahr als studentin im
damaligen leningrad den großen schritt
nach moskau machte sie 1994 eine zeit in
der das neue russland zwar freiheiten
hatte aber auch unruhe chaos und armut
ersten an den demonstrationen habe ich
nicht teilgenommen
ich gebe für die politik habe ich mich
nicht sehr interessiert
[Musik]
aus liebe zu ihrem mann einem russischen
schauspieler ist sie damals hergekommen
sie musste sich eine arbeit suchen und
dann das russische leben gewöhnen
konsumgüter gab es ganz neu aus china
und aus dem westen aber kaum jemand
konnte sie sich leisten
ich bin mit zwei koffern und zwei
meerschweinchen angekommen für mich war
es hier fast eine frage des überlebens
in der wohnung die mein mann vom theater
erhalten hatte gab es absolut nichts
manche sagten ja was bringst du für ein
opfer die wunderbare schweiz zu
verlassen für das furchtbare russland
wie groß muss die liebe sein aber es war
nicht nur die liebe zu meinem
an sondern auch eine große neugier eine
schwierige aber prägende zeit von null
anzufangen war aber spannend ich liebte
diese erfahrung schritt für schritt ging
es vorwärts
heute habe ich eine eigene wohnung keine
meerschweinchen mehr aber zwei katzen
und einen hund und vor allem eine
tochter alles in allem ein gutes leben
findet sie
auftakt zur pia export der bedeutendsten
fachmesse für hotellerie in moskau in
dem pavillon in dem es ausschließlich um
tee und kaffee geht treffen wir es wird
lange und ihren australischen freund
tieren
dieses jahr haben sie neben ihren
hochwertigen kaffee sorten auch rost
maschinen im angebot
die doppel strategie scheint aufzugehen
jeder dort über zwei maschinen
ausgestellt sie sind bereits verfahren
die 1 media und news jetzt zweimal an
china verkaufen
eine solche messe bedeutet fürs mit
langer startup drei tage ausnahmezustand
potenzielle kunden informieren sich hier
über neue trends
wer schläft den erwartet ein böses
erwachen
es ist anstrengend es läuft viel aber
wir machen viel degustationen drin so
neue kunden
super kirin und svetlana haben noch
einen weiteren termin dafür verwandelt
sich die 26-jährige von der hippen café
zur eleganten business lady eine halbe
taxi stunde entfernt wartet schon vater
george auf eine andere messe imex
prozent das junge paar hat ihm seine
unterstützung zugesagt
mutet sich svetlana nicht etwas viel zu
und durch die
[Musik]
langsamer angehen so könnte auch das
motto von lorenz widmer und seiner
familie lauten
der schulalltag hat noch nicht begonnen
eine routine gibt es noch nicht dafür
ist die wohnung schon eingerichtet
sie scheint jedoch immer noch ein
bisschen leer oder ist das so gewollt
schon länger kenne es besonders wichtig
die christenheit und die rechte hand zum
ball dass möbel zu sehen haben sie sich
sehr stark der heimweg für den sprint in
rosenfeld nötig glaubt erkennt wenn
diese große lorenz neuer job ist auf
vier jahre angelegt danach geht es wohl
wieder zurück ein abenteuer auf zeit ist
das ein vor oder ein nachteil
also ich finde ich dass ich noch nicht
mal für ihre versüßen den sie das ganze
dann kurz
lorenz neues büro im swiss business hub
ist sogar zu fuß erreichbar
die kita von tochter nora liegt auf dem
weg und ist so exklusiv dass wir drinnen
nicht filmen dürfen
dass ich jetzt in private kita dass ich
lieber das bedingt dass mit der sprache
situation vorerst nicht ins meer eine
private lösung damit sie bc flexibilität
das ist klar sicherung typisch für
russland und typisch für russland wäre
noch vor ein paar jahren auch der große
park gewesen denn lorenz auf seinem weg
zur arbeit durchquert natürlich das ist
sehr unterschiedlich spannen sollte das
imperium des bösen irgendwie so als
jugendlicher den ist das wort das mit
dem ok und ich glaube es ist viel mehr
nötig sei sogar ein piercing westermann
völker pflicht der schalter war zum
kleid und russland wird es genau wie ich
wiemer und dass ich wahrscheinlich nicht
ganz unrealistisch erwarte ich sie es
sich jetzt anders
aber trotzdem ist es offensichtlich dass
russland in serien bemerkenswerte
entwicklung ist oft die letzte 21 25
jahren
moskau verfügt über einige überraschende
facetten bauunternehmer roland lay hat
sich mit seinem deutschen freund siggi
zu einem kleinen segeltörn auf dessen
boot verabredet ein idyllisches segel
paradies fast wie auf einem schweizer
see allerdings hat die krise auch hier
spuren hinterlassen
da ist praktisch kein platz
und immerhin mehr als elf die reformen
ist jetzt großes aber von denen gibt es
nicht sehr viele das thema der hütte
immer immer da
das eu-verfahren jetzt kommen die frauen
rolands lebensgefährtin katja und sieges
frau lena sind beide waschechte
russinnen
die besatzung ist komplett es kann
losgehen
kapitän zedi überlässt seinem freund
roland heute das ruder
doch der 61 jährige scheint ein bisschen
aus der übung zu sein
kein problem
und ein bisschen zeit zu üben bleibt ja
noch in der moscow city dem neuen
geschäftsviertel der zwölf millionen
metropole sind mit lan und tieren auf
der zweiten messe angekommen
am stand von svetlana vater george geht
es um die wurst
seit kurzem ist klar svetlana und tieren
werden parallel zum kaffee auch das
fleisch geschäft vorantreiben
warners vater kam bereits in den 90ern
nach russland wo mit maschinen zu
handeln
die frage der nachfolge war lange
ungeklärt ist jetzt auch wieder licht am
ende des tunnels weil ich heute doch
nicht besorgt gestartet und es geschafft
wird dafür im sommer für diese schau dir
fragt sie was machen meine momentane für
jeden doch dass das jetzt jeder hilft es
sich beruhigen
ich rede ja schon aber es ist schon
jetzt unter normalen umständen wäre das
alles sehr beängstigend aber ich habe
großes vertrauen in swetlana und und
george george geht ja nicht einfach
sondern er wird dafür sorgen dass wir
gut mit allem zurechtkommen
also ich glaube fest an unsere zukunft
nur ein paar kilometer weiter gibt es
ebenfalls einen grund zu feiern
einweihungsparty in der neuen wohnung
von jury und ehemann andre die eigenen
vier wände und vor allem die küche
traditionell der raum für geselligkeit
in russland
es gibt immer diese öffentliche orte wo
alle einnahmen das sehen und zu hause
bisschen zu hause da sie die vielleicht
niemand und du lädst nur die leute die
du gerne hast die du magst mit denen du
vielleicht die geheimnisse miterleben
könntest ja und das ist natürlich eine
alle kulturen eine rückkehr in ihre alte
heimat ist für sie eigentlich kaum
denkbar
ich sage ich es nicht auch keine
illusion
das thema resozialisierbar kite in der
alten heimat ist eines das auch roland
lay beschäftigt seit er vor über 20
jahren nach russland kam hatte er immer
mal wieder mit gegenwind zu kämpfen
sie schauen wo wir hingehen noch mehr
motoren kann so
und auch wenn sich am horizont dunkle
wolken zeigen roland held das steuer
fest in der hand untätig daneben zu
sitzen ist nicht sein ding
wenn man geschäfte in russland so ist
ausnahme wenn freundin katja mal
ansteuern möchte ein schönes motiv
findet sieges freundin lena
ein perfekter sonntag für den
bauunternehmer auch wenn entspannungen
zeiten wie diesen nicht immer leicht
fällt
aber bedenken
noch schlimmer aber vorerst chef das ist
klar
rolands baustelle neigen sich dem ende
zu und noch immer ist kein neues
großprojekt in sicht wie ernst ist die
lage gerade erlebt das baugeschäft eine
schwierige phase aber ich glaube es ist
nur vorübergehend eine kleine krise
vielleicht muss ein land demnächst öfter
in die schweiz und zur hälfte dort und
zur hälfte in russland leben
ich würde dann bleiben und ab und zu in
der schweiz urlaub machen
aber was wenn sich die kleine krise doch
als große entpuppt hängt davon wie sich
die geschäfte entwickeln womöglich auch
rolands beziehung zu freundin katja ab
war willi merz darüber gedanken mache
ich weiß nicht wie situation die nicht
auch wie bisher nicht lernt teilen
russland will versuchts plane in zukunft
wie es für dich sowieso anders die sich
rund um fluss denke wenn man so viel zu
machen
zurück auf der messe für heute sind die
geschäfte gemacht
alle sind müde aber gelöst für swetlana
beginnt eine spannende zeit
wie wird sich freund kevin im
familienunternehmen behaupten so für
mich ein typisches aktive schon
ausstrahle halten wenn es um kreativität
gefehlt trend oder neue methode für mich
aus meiner sicht für meine tochter jetzt
wichtig ist es ist so eine die hexen und
teufel ruhiger pol
und das ist es was sie braucht es
endlich gesetzliche temperament
situationen aber dass es funktioniert
ich hoffe das bleibt die nacht kehrt 1
in der russischen hauptstadt
wer kann zieht sich in seine
privatsphäre zurück
am liebsten mit guten freunden
[Musik]
ja
das film von den alliierten nach es ist
ja auch wie man sehen konnte
gemeinsam soll im winter hätten
ich habe ab und zu schon unsere sechs
schweizer haben sich im wilden osten ein
spannendes leben aufgebaut und moskau
verändert sich so rasant dass es
bestimmt spannend bleiben wird
[Musik]